you talk about that performance you did
in the the first episode and it was this
big powerful moving performance
addressing kind of black lives matter
george floyd and that stuff
and did anyone kind of say oh
some people may not like this was there
was there any inkling that this
was a risky thing to do i mean we knew
we knew full well that people wouldn't
like it
but i wasn't quite ready for the amount
of people
i wasn't quite ready to you know be um
across national news for three weeks
with people telling me that it wasn't
the time or place and
somehow i ended up being the racist i
don't know how that one works but
all i tried to do was a summary of 2020
and kind of like you know
create something that kind of ended up
like as a
moment of hope and coming together and
tried to end positively and
it was like a look back and somehow it
got turned into something that touched a
really raw nerve and
i'm glad it did you know you got like 10
000 complaints
no no 27. oh man well i mean we were
climbing
to the most complained about tv moment
of the day i really wanted number one i
felt like i was climbing the charts
i really did but we got to number two
and then kind of offcom ruled that they
weren't going to investigate
but like i suppose is there any kind of
bright
sort of silver lining in the yes there
are 27 000 complaints
but were you kind of i don't know
encouraged by how strongly
ofcom knocked it back how itv supported
you you know what it's uh it's a moment
it's i feel like it's genuinely like a
moment for like race relations in this
country you know you've got
itv who backed us and they you know
spent
a huge amount of money advertising
across every national paper with a full
page
ad saying we stand by what happened
offcom rule to not investigate and for
me
that's what change looks like and i
think it's really important to sort of
say that
not everybody that complained about the
routine as
is racist i think it's a really
interesting sort of thing i think that
it made some people uncomfortable yeah i
think it made people
feel oh i don't want to you know see
this when i'm eating my fish and chips
but actually i think it's that's why i
think it's perfect because there are a
lot of people that just can't turn that
stuff
off so i actually thought you know what
if you can have people talking about
climate change and you know things that
have happened to them in their life why
shouldn't i be able to use four minutes
to talk about something that's affected
me and mine and countless other people
yeah so um yeah super proud and
yeah i think it was i would never take
it back no well done yes
you